6 26 on your wednesday morning now this
is right next door so we should not
treat it like it's another world away
especially when it affects your drive to
utah so remember once you get past
mesquite on the i-15 you got 29 miles
worth of the grand canyon state to get
through and that's where friendly heads
up from adot comes in the arizona
department of transportation just
started a three-year-long project
they're going to be replacing this mile
long bridge over the virgin river near
the town of littlefield the biggest
impact only one lane of traffic in both
directions 24 7. so depending on the
timing of your trip you could be in for
long delays so not only is there a web
page with great information there's also
an app that frequent drivers through the
area might want to consider downloading
it's called virgin river bridge we've
got those links as well as all of our
driving you crazy stories on our website
8newsnow.com click traffic then driving
you crazy buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone if there is
something driving you crazy email me
traffic 8 8newsnow.com